and your face was surprised as the big
news of today you've got a 24 year old
linebacker after one breakout year
fantastic draft pick by you guys
announcing his retirement what do you
make of Chris Borland retirement you
know we respected and I love Chris he's
a great kid and you know it's certainly
a surprise to to us and I think to some
of his teammates but you have to respect
the decision if he you know fears for
his health and safety going forward you
know I don't ever want somebody to go
out there and do something but they're
not comfortable doing and I would never
try to talk somebody out of retirement
and it wasn't an easy decision for him
but you know we respect and we wish him
the best when you go across the
defensive corps of your defensive
oriented team I mean you've got Patrick
Willis retiring you've got you know it's
unclear what's happening with Justin
Smith you've got Chris Borland leaving
what do we know what's happening with
Justin Smith yet so Justin's been
working out the guys I'm not sure if
he's made up his mind yet I know he's
still in that decision-making process we
obviously would love to have Justin back
but but he's got to he's got to be
comfortable going out there you know
putting his body through it one more
year and if he's not you know we're
gonna have to to step up and and have
somebody else make plays